POINT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
>>> NOW, THE POWER OF PEOPLE AND
THE POWER OF PROTESTS HAVE
DRIVEN THIS MOVEMENT FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE AT THE FORE FRONT, BLACK
LIVES MATTER.
I'M JOINED NOW BY ITS COWILL
HAVE FOUNDER.
WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
WE'RE ASKING EVERYBODY TODAY, WA
WAS YOUR IMMEDIATE SENSE WHEN
YOU HEARD THAT VERDICT HANDED
DOWN?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
MY IMMEDIATE FEELING WHEN I
HEARD THE VERDICT WAS ONE OF
RELIEF.
E DIDN'T EXPECT TO FEEL SO
EMOTIONAL.
I HAD TUNED OUT TO A CERTAIN
DEGREE BECAUSE OF THE EMOTIONAL
KIND OF TOLL ALL OF THESE CASES
AND ACTS OF VIOLENCE AND THE
SHOOTINGS WE HAVE BEEN HEARING
ABOUT, IN ADDITION TO WATCHING
THE TRIAL AND I KIND OF -- I
ALLOWED MYSELF TO TAKE A STEP
BACK AND TO NOT BE TIED TO THE
TV EVERY SINGLE DAY AND BY TIME
I FINALLY WENT TO LISTEN TO THE
VERDICT, I WAS COMPLETELY
OVERWHELMED.
I WAS MOVED TO TEARS.
I COULDN'T HELP BUT THINK ABOUT
GEORGE FLOYD, HIS LOVED ONES,
HIS GORGEOUS DAUGHTER, HIS
FAMILY AND THE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD WHO
DEMANDED THAT WE SEE THAT HIS
MURDER BE BROUGHT TO SOME SORT
OF QUOTE, UNQUOTE JUSTICE OR
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THIS CASE.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU HOW TO DO
YOU FEEL PERSONALLY?
YOU'RE ONE OF THREE CO-FOUNDERS
OF BLACK LIVES MATTER MOVEMENT.
PEOPLE STAYED ON THE STREETS.
PROTESTS AND ACTIVISM HAPPENED
ALL THIS YEAR, MOSTLY BLACK
PEOPLE BUT MANY MILLIONS OF
WHITE PEOPLE SQUJOINING AS WELLD
AROUND THE WORLD.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT YOUR -- I
WOULD SAY YOUR TRANSFORMATIVE
IMPACT ON WHAT WE SEE TRANSPIRE
IN THE COURTROOM?
>> YOU KNOW, THIS IS A REAL
TESTAMENT TO THE POWER OF THE
PEOPLE.
THE POWER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
MOVED SO DEEPLY FROM A SENSE OF
THEY'RE OWN RIGHTEOUSNESS AND
CONNECTION TO HUMANITY AND MOVE
FROM THEIR OWN MORAL CONVICTION
TO SAY, WE'RE GOING TO THE
STREETS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PANDEMIC.
WE CAN'T SIT IDLY BY WHILE OUR
NEIGHBORS ARE BEING GUNNED DOWN
AND LEFT TO BE CHOKED TO DEATH
IN BROAD DAYLIGHT.
I THINK PEOPLE WERE ULTIMATELY
FED UP AND LAST YEAR WE SAW
HISTORIC UPRISINGS AND I THINK
NEW YORK TIMES SAID IT WAS
LARGEST MOVEMENT IN HISTORY,
AROUND THE WORLD.
IT'S REALLY ABOUT EVERY DAY
PEOPLE TAKING OWNERSHIP OF THEIR
LIVE, TAKING OWNERSHIP OF THEIR
DESTINY AND BECOMING THE TYPE OF
CITIZEN RI THAT WE DESERVE SO WE
CAN TRANSFORM OUR SOCIETY AND
HAVE A WORLD WHERE BLACK PEOPLE
ARE FINALLY TREATED WITH DIGNITY
AND RESPECT THAT WE DESERVE.
TO ME THIS REALLY A TESTAMENT OF
THE PEOPLE, EVERY DAY PEOPLE
TAKING TO THE STREETS AND SAYING
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
WE HAVE KNOWN FOR FAR TOO LONG
THAT THIS KIND OF VIOLENCE AND
KILLING OF UNARMED BLACK PEOPLE
CONTINUES TO PLAGUE THERE
COUNTRY.
WE'RE TIRED OF IT.
WE KNOW WE CAN'T LET THIS GO ON
AND WE TO LET GO OF THE A PATHY.
I'M MUOVED BY EVERY SINGLE PERSN
WHO MOVED THEIR FEET TO THE
STREET.
PEOPLE OF ALL AILS WERE OUT LAST
YEAR.
THIS IS A BIG KUDOS TO EVERYBODY
WO WAS MOVED AND WHO GOT INTO
THE STREETS.
I WILL ALSO SAY IT'S SAD IT
WOULD TAKE THAT TYPE OF GLOBAL
UPRISING TO SEE THIS TYPE OF
VERDICT.
>> ALSI WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE
FUTURE.
MANY ARE SAYING WE WANT TO
CELEBRATE BUT WE CAN'T REALLY
CELEBRATE.
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE
FUTURE EVEN GEORGE FLOYD'S
BROTHER SAYS, I THINK TODAY HAS
BEEN AN OCCASION WHERE PEOPLE
CAN CELEBRATE BUT TOMORROW IT'S
BACK TO BUSINESS.
FOR ALL AFRICAN-AMERICANS, FOR
ALL BLACK PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND AROUND THE WORLD,
WHAT DO YOU -- WHERE DOES THIS
CONVICTION STAND?
DO YOU THINK IT'S
TRANSFORMATIVE?
DO YOU HAVE TO KEEP PEOPLE ON
THE STREET AND KEEP UP THE
STRUGGLE?
>> TO BE QUITE HONEST, THIS
VERDICT IS NOT TRANSFORMATIVE.
THIS IS ONE INCIDENT WHERE WE
SEE THAT THERE IS ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR A MURDER THAT WAS CAUGHT ON
CAMERA IN BROAD DAYLIGHT IN
WHICH MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD WITNESSED BY VIRTUE OF
SEEING THE VIDEO FOOTAGE AND
SAYING ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE.
I THINK THIS ONE VERDICT CANNOT
BE SEEN AS WHAT IS GOING TO NOW
BECOME THE STATUS QUO UNLESS WE
SEE THE CHANGE, UNLESS WE SEE
THE TYPE OF INVESTMENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE REALLOCATION
OF POLICING DOLLARS TOWARD OTHER
SOLUTIONS THAT KEEP EVERY DAY
PEOPLE SAFE.
THAT'S ULTIMATELY WHAT I BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED.
THEY HAVE TO LOOK AT SOLUTIONS
THAT RESPECT THE BEST OF US AND
RESPECT BLACK LIFE.
THAT LOOKS AT WHERE ARE OUR
DOLLARS GOING.
WHAT ARE WE DOING WITH THE
RESOURCES?
WHAT CAN WE DO INSTEAD?
WHAT KIND OF DECISIONS CAN WE
MAKE THAT LOOKS AT PEOPLE WITH
DIGNITY AS OPPOSED TO BEING A
PROBLEM OR SEEING US AS A
CRIMINAL RIGHT OFF T